je suis pas spécialement maniaque bon
bon j'aime bien quand c'est un petit peu
propre et bien rangé
bon d'accord mon appartement ressemble à
une public et à mais je suis comme tout
le monde il ya des petites choses comme
ça qui me dégoûte un petit peu comme la
sensation de la cuvette chaude sous mes
fesses quand je vais aux toilettes après
quelqu'un et je peux pas m'empêcher
d'imaginer un mec bien dégueulasse
assise juste avant pour me dégoûte et
ayame verrue tous mes fesses qui me
gratte parce que j'aime bien me dégoûter
je sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs quand je
vais dans les toilettes publiques j'ai
ma petite technique d'autistes qui
consiste à mettre du papier toilette
tout autour de la cuve est alors je
reconnais sur l'échelle du style à ce
moment là je suis au plus bas je peux
pas pechoux en faisant ça et à chaque
fois que je fais ça je me dis mais si
tout le monde fait comme moi dans ce cas
là ces toilettes sont carrément propre
donc pas besoin de mettre du papier
toilette sur la cuvette
et oui mais je suis pas fou 1up
troisième couche en vrai dans ma tête
tout a basculé depuis que j'ai vu cette
pub non reconnu et non chez moi les
champignons je m'incruste sous les
ongles et je m'installe avec mes copains
nous gagnons du terrain pas facile de
nous déloger des ongles jauni et
pessines décoller parlez-en à votre
médecin et il diffuser cette pub à
l'heure du dîner
essaye de manger en regardant ça on ne
me dérange pas nous tombons fonds union
d'ailleurs en parlant d'hygiène on va
établir une règle très simple qu'on va
appliquer dès à présent tout de suite
tout ce qu'ils touchent votre bouche
vous appartient d'accord ça ne sert à
rien de vouloir partager
alors parfois on peut esquiver un j'ai
une technique c'est que mon cerveau
établi les zones sans danger c'est bon
ça faisait gouttes
bon quand quelqu'un boit la bouteille et
veut faire boire après j'utilise la
technique que j'appelle boire en wifi
elle est rafraîchissante 1 alors c'est
un peu paradoxal parce qu'en fait ma
propre crasse je m'en fout en fait
brasles par exemple sur les souris
d'ordinateur est toujours un petit peu
de crasse c'est normal et on s'en fout
par contre si c'est la souris de
quelqu'un d'autre mais l'objet qui
attire le plus la crasse sur la planète
terre les gamers savent c'est la manette
site est très très courageux tu peux
même pas c'est le cure dent dans la
petite rainures là
ça c'est pour les fous il ya des gens
ils s'en foutent de tout rien rien ne
les dégoûte j'aimerais j'aimerais
tellement être comme ces gens là bon il
ya un truc que je pourrai jamais de la
vie par contre embrasser son chien non
un chien passe son temps à renifler les
culs d'autres chiens et à se lécher les
parties génitales
donc non nana10 le reconnais je suis pas
un exemple d'hygiène non plus voilà je
vais vous avoir un truc parfois dans la
journée je me cure un peu le nez voilà
comme un enfant de 4 ans ah tiens mais
attention c'est pas parce que je suis
crade
au contraire c'est parce que je veux
éviter à tout prix
cette situation salut les filles oui oui
c'est moi c'est cyprien de youtube alors
la star du net on peut dire ça comme ça
a bien sûr bien sûr oui oui je vais pas
vous cacher j'ai quelques petits projets
en terme de cinéma voilà en fait j'ai
vécu des expériences assez traumatisante
en termes d'hygiène des images que je
pourrai jamais oublier
quand on me positionne sur le visage par
exemple tu veux faire un film où
l'histoire allait
mo
et là je me prends le postillon et je
fais style de rien histoire n est pas si
importante mais pas alors que dans ma
tête je dois prendre une douche tous
j'ai vécu un autre truc du genre
un mec qui voulait absolument me faire
écouter un truc d un groupe de musique
je peux te faire écouter ou qu'est ce
que tu veux avec des écouteurs intra
auriculaires
voilà mes fans et comme j'ai dit que je
voulais bien écouté son truc je pouvais
pas reculer ce que j'ai fait c'est sympa
ce que je pensais à la voix ça ta [ __ ]
de merde merde pedro crado va crever
blackrock va crever mais si non je suis
normal un jeu 1-2 partez pas
c'est du rock and roll